six foot seven out of kansas city
missouri
this is byu's men's basketball team
getting hyped for one of their first
tests in this year's ncaa tournament
a test for the coronavirus
[Music]
march madness is now underway i'm back
and kovan 19 is the opponent
every team is facing in the tournament's
first weekend an
outbreak on one roster forced a team to
forfeit before even taking the court
others have competed without key players
the winning team is going to be that
that
can keep themselves safe as possible
right but safety isn't just up to the
teams
the ncaa has created so-called
controlled environments in indianapolis
where the men are playing
and san antonio where the women are in
order
to pull this off the ncaa did what it
does best which is
write lots and lots of rules last year
the virus put march madness in the
nearly 900 million dollars in revenue it
brings
on ice so what are the protocols the
ncaa put in place to keep covet 19 from
upending this year's tournament
and are they working
last year we knew nothing about this
virus now we know a lot
now we have testing last year last year
part of the reason we
we cancelled the tournament is there
wasn't enough testing available to do
the testing we needed to do
much of the ncaa's covet 19 playbook
centers around
testing quarantining masking and
distancing
just to enter the controlled environment
players and coaches were all required to
report
seven consecutive days of negative tests
i'm in quarantine right now
then upon arrival everyone had to
complete a 48-hour quarantine
we got tested about an hour ago they are
getting tested every day
they don't have roommates in their hotel
rooms every floor of the hotel
has its own team and getting to practice
involves a very intricate dance of
timing of you know who can be in the
elevator when when they can walk across
the lobby
everything down to the minutia is
thought of
that's because one negative test has the
potential to cause a domino effect you
know that's a bucket
once a player tests positive any other
player that is deemed as a close contact
will also be required to quarantine
potentially missing the opportunity to
play
some people say well you know you're
being too cautious absolutely i think
you're being cautious because
there's a lot of a lot of things are at
stake here for the ncaa
what's at stake is 80 of its annual
revenue
which the association banks on the men's
basketball tournament
to bring in when the ncaa's revenue gets
curtailed
that means that all of the money that it
gives out to support the athletic
departments at
every one of the thousand member
institutions that make up the ncaa
they also get hurt and they get less
money last year the ncaa's distribution
to all schools was projected to be 600
million dollars
it ended up being just 225 million after
the tournament was cancelled
in order to avoid kind of an existential
financial crisis
the ncaa really made it a priority to
make sure that it could hold the
tournament this year and continue to
recoup some of those revenues
for players and coaches what's at stake
is the chance to be national champions
a title vcu's men's team lost before
they even took the court
the team reported multiple positive
tests in the 48 hours preceding their
first round game
bcu did not specify how many members
were deemed close contacts and thus
required to quarantine
but teams need a minimum of five healthy
players to compete
this is what you dream of as a college
player and a coach and
to get it taken away like this is uh
it's just
uh it's a heartbreaking moment in their
in their young lives
we knew this was gonna happen there will
be teams that you will find with
somebody infected because
there's enough virus transmission in the
community that that that was going to be
the case and unfortunately you know we
are seeing that
but the virus has impacted teams in
other ways oklahoma played without its
second leading scorer
and defending champions virginia lost
their first round match-up after forced
quarantines from an earlier outbreak
impacted their practice schedule i think
you're going to be continuing seeing
this kind of things and i think
hopefully teams are going to be looking
at
at their protocols and what they're
doing and learning from this and saying
could we do something different
while dr del rio says the ncaa's covet
protocols are comprehensive
its controlled environment isn't
impenetrable
they have to find a way to you know not
run into trouble with this and it's an
incredibly unpredictable and contagious
virus so
it's sort of this x factor that's
hanging over every team's tournament
[Applause]
runs